what's the state plan for those of a dog
the heart of a Marine
sounds like a hero to me they're so
proud of you both come say goodbye to
your brother Justin leave him be
I'm just over here dealing with a minor
insurgency he's trying to save the whole
universe I thought it was gonna see it
work this morning eight am waste my
summer did what are they doing here
[Music]
max bonded so close to the Kyle he can't
work with anyone else are you sure you
want to do this I gotta go take care of
that dog only let me touch him bro I can
come over and show you a few tricks
max does has to know that you want him
it's a start
so what's max like a bad dog max was as
good a dog as ever passed through this
facility animals can come down with post
traumatic stress same as people can max
it'll be okay
a million lies but now I tell a single
boy yes you win everything I do want to
tell you how sorry God was the best
friend that I ever had
Tyler's someone you should stay away
from I'm talking about some bad business
here your brother always wanted to be a
hero look where it got him what do you
got in those crates dad's left a really
weird message you disappeared Flores did
it max go search
it's just a kid and his dog out there
let's go it's my only fear that my dad
we got the Air Jordan of dogs here man
what we stay steep fall asleep you been
out here all night
I don't want to talk about